[Musique]
bon tu continues là je vais sans moi je
reviens dans deux minutes gelé à part
continuer à faire c'est peut-être là ça
lui arrive sans arrêt de partir sans
dire où il va peut-être mais moi chaque
fois que casimir disparaît je ne peux
pas m'empêcher d'être un fiat ou n'a pas
disparu il a laissé une lettre disant
qu'il partait un expédition la relique
gelé nous l'avons déjà lu quatre fois ça
me fait rien je n'ai peut-être pas fait
très attention il ya peut-être un indice
qui nous permettraient de savoir où il
est parti bon jeu de la relire une
cinquième fois
mon cher françois
la jolie julie tout ce qu'ils les gens
qui disent pas je continue et j'ai
décidé d'être désigné cette année le
plus grand explorateur de l'île aux
enfants
je pars banques pour une très grande
expédition dont je garde la destination
secrète
quand vous lirez cette lettre je serais
parti par le bateau de 4h38 et bien
justement voilà un avis j'ai un petit
livre des horaires de bateaux peut-être
que nous allons trouver une indication
4h38 voici 4 heures 38 navires rapides
pour les antilles et le groenland
je ne demande pour laquelle de ces deux
destinations casimir est parti continue
à lire je crois me souvenir qu'il ya un
autre indice bon jeu je reprends ne vous
inquiétez pas pour moi je me couvrir est
très chaudement à bientôt
casimir et bien tu vois voilà un indice
très intéressant si casimir parle de se
couvrir chaudement sais qu'il est parti
pour un pays froid et très bon
raisonnement
il faut donc voir pour quel pays froids
le bateau que casimir a pris est parti
et voilà les suppressions il n'y a que
deux destinations attend maintenant que
je retrouve d'abord les antilles à
l'honneur les antilles ça ne peut pas
être ça les antilles sont un groupe
d'îles où il fait toujours très chaud
c'est c'est là que se trouvent les îles
de la guadeloupe et de la martinique et
l'autre escale c'est le groenland
comment n'y allons pas songé plus tôt
mais c'est évident qu'il s'agit du
groenland
ça va être terriblement dur pour lui et
il le fait tellement froid
le groenland se trouvent presque
entièrement dans le cercle polaire nord
en cette saison il est déjà recouvert
entièrement par la glace il a fallu des
hommes très courageux et très entraînés
comme paul emile victor pour l'explorer
il n'y arrivera jamais tout seul
j'en ai peur je né sais bien que tu vois
que j'avais raison d'être inquiet je lis
tu entends pas parce que je me dis tu
veux qu'elle soit nombre à nouveau cette
voie bonjour casimir quelle joie de te
voir qui n'est pas bienvenue aux non pas
du tout ça va très bien j'ai l'honneur
de vous annoncer que le plus grand
explorateur de l'île aux enfants est en
pleine forme après véritable oui tu
allais racontez nous tout va bien je
suis allé au groenland un jeu remonter
le cours de plusieurs fleuves mais je
vais en faire un jeu avec les enfants tu
vas casimir j'ai peur que les fleuves du
groenland soit un petit peu difficile
pour eux ah bon alors comme ce n'est pas
quand l'idée que veut me gâcher mon jeu
mais pas du tout quasiment avant un coup
touch je te laisse fait-on je viens
julie d'accord bon les enfants venus là
on est tous à rené bonnet on va faire un
jeu ensemble ouais voilà je vous
explique
il va falloir que vous trouviez les noms
des fleuves quand j'ai remonté d'accord
et vous aussi chez vous vous pouvez
jouer avec nous
alors je suis parti d'une grande villa
qui s'appelait le havre ça me donnerait
bien curieux pour un fleuve du grain
j'ai remonté le fleuve qui parlent ce
port et je suis arrivé dans une autre
grande ville qui s'appelle ou et ensuite
je suis arrivé draps dans la capitale de
ce pays qui s'appelle paris la capitale
vous connaissez ce fleurs alors pardon
c'est la scène c'est ça il ya quelque
chose de louche dans tout ça je suis
ensuite à arriver à l'embouchure d'un
deuxième fleuve
il y avait également un port qui
s'appelait saint nazaire j'ai vu
d'autres villes sur ce fleuve qui
s'appelait gloire saumur
il y avait d'ailleurs tous pour l'eau de
très beaux châteaux
vous connaissez ce frère la loire c'est
la loire et que julie il les sons de
terminer son jeu nous tirerons ça au
clair plus tard le troisième fleuve que
j'ai vu à commencer par un immense
estuaire au fond de cet estuaire il y
avait une grande ville qui s'appelle
bordeaux une avis suivante s'appelle
agen et là j'ai mangé des très bons
pruneaux je suis ensuite arriver dans
une troisième grande ville sur ce fleuve
où j'ai mangé un délicieux cassoulet
cette grande ville s'appelle toulouse et
je suis remonté jusqu'à sa source dans
les pyrénées comment s'appelle ce fleuve
non la carole et et vous chez vous est
ce que vous aviez trouvé et comment
s'appelle le pays dans la dans lequel se
trouvent ces fleuves annoncé c'est le
groenland
mais non c'est le groenland
je t'assure que non c'est le grand est
que se passe-t-il si on vous entend du
bout du jardin
bonjour factor c'est casimir qui n'est
pas d'accord avec les enfants sur les
géographies à aubes ajustements casimir
tiens je viens de voir madame bouquin 1
la libraire bas elle m'a dit que tu t'es
trompé
tu as remporté la carte de géographie de
la france à la place de celle du
groenland
bon alors là la scène là la loire et la
carotte ne le sont pas aux grandes
langues
mais les enfants ont déjà répondu je
crois pas qu à vis et comment le bateau
de 4h38 a pu te déposée en france
pour sûr ça ne risque pas parce que le
bateau de 4h38 ça fait au moins quinze
jours qu'il est supprimé
casimir qui n'a jamais quitté l'île aux
enfants
tu as menti aux anges je je n'ai pas
vraiment menti j'ai j'ai inventé au bon
en tout cas du ne peut pas être le le
plus grand explorateur de l'île aux
enfants
bon et bien tant pis je saurai le plus
grands inventeurs
[Musique]